DINNER PARTY THAT GOVERNOR
NEWSOM ATTENDED.
SO WILL THE PUSH TO OUST NEWSOM
PROVE TO BE SUCCESSFUL?
LET’S ASK THE WOMAN WHO IS PART
OF THE GOLDEN STATE’S 2003
GOVERNOR GRAY DAVIS RECALL,
TAMMY BRUCE.
TAMMY, HAPPY NEW YEAR.
THANKS FOR JOINING US.
>> SAME TO YOU.
MY PLEASURE, GREAT WAY TO START
THE NEW YEAR.
GRIFF: IT IS, INDEED.
I THINK THIS IS A STORY THAT’S
REALLY GOING TO GAIN STEAM.
SINCE 1911, I BELIEVE IT IS, 55
TIMES CALIFORNIA’S TRIED TO
RECALL THEIR GOVERNOR, BUT ONLY
ONCE WAS IT SUCCESSFUL.
YOU WERE A PART OF IT IN 2003,
RECALLING GOVERNOR DAVIS.
OF COURSE, WE GOT ARNOLD
SCHWARZENEGGER OUT OF IT.
WHAT DO YOU SEE IN PARALLEL
BETWEEN THEN AND NOW?
>> WELL, THAT WAS A REAL
POPULIST EFFORT, IT WAS,
OBVIOUSLY, THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
INVOLVED IN ORGANIZING.
BUT IT -- THE SIMILAR THING IS,
OF COURSE, THE PEOPLE OF THE
SOUTHWEST, PEOPLE OF THE WEST OF
THIS COUNTRY REALLY STILL ARE
REVOLUTIONARIES.
WE ALL ARE AT HEART, RIGHT?
IT’S IN OUR DNA.
I THINK WHAT CALIFORNIANS, WHILE
ALL AMERICANS ARE GENERALLY, OF
COURSE, TOLERANT, WE’RE QUIET
PEOPLE, WHAT THEY DON’T LIKE IS
UNFAIRNESSES, THEY DON’T LIKE
BEING LIED TO, AND THAT’S WHAT
GAVIN NEWSOM DID, THAT’S WHAT
GRAY DAVIS WAS DOING TO THE
STATE AS WELL.
ALSO NEGATIVE IMPACT ON THE
ECONOMY.
SO THIS IS REALLY A NONPARTISAN
ISSUE.
SO I THINK THAT THEY CAN HAVE
SUCCESS.
I CERTAINLY HOPE THEY DO.
SCHWARZENEGGER WAS NOT A
SUCCESS, SO MY ONLY WARNING IS.
WHEN YOU DO THIS RECALL, MAKE
SURE THAT THERE’S A LOT OF
THOUGHT PUT INTO WHO IT IS
THAT’S BEING ENCOURAGED TO RUN.
THERE ARE OVER 60 PEOPLE BY THE
WAY, GRIFF, WHO RAN FOR GOVERNOR
ON THE SAME BALLOT AS THE RECALL
IN 2003.
IT WAS A FABULOUS EXPERIENCE.
IT WAS A NONPARTISAN RACE.
AND WE KNOW THAT THE PROCESS
WORKED WELL.
BUT I THINK THAT THIS IS A
WARNING TO EVERYONE, IT’S THE
ECONOMY, THE HANDLING OF COVID,
THE CORRUPTION, THIS LOBBYIST
GUY.
CALIFORNIANS DON’T LIKE IT, AND
I THINK THEY’LL BE SUCCESSFUL.
GRIFF: AND IT’S FASCINATING, IN
2003, OF COURSE, DAVIS WAS
DEALING WITH AN ENERGY CRISIS,
HIS FAILURES THERE LED TO THE
RECALL.
NOW WE HAVE NEWSOM AND HIS
FAILURES ENABLING COVID-19 -- IN
THE HANDLING COVID-19.
HOW CLOSE THOUGH IS THIS TO
ACTUALLY SUCCEEDING?
WE KNOW YOU NEED A MILLION AND A
HALF SIGNATURES, THEY’VE GOT A
LITTLE OVER 800,000.
>> THAT’S RIGHT.
GRIFF: WE JUST SAW A FIRM GIVE
HALF A MILLION DOLLARS TO THIS
EFFORT.
HOW LIKELY IS IT TO SUCCEED?
>> WELL, THE CAMPAIGN ITSELF HAS
NOTED ON SOCIAL MEDIA THAT A LOT
OF THAT MONEY WE’VE HEARD, BIG
DONATIONS, ARE GOOD.
THEY’RE NOT IN CASH NOW, AND
THEY NEED PAID CIRCULATORS.
THAT’S WHAT OUR EXPERIENCE WAS
IN 2003, THAT THE POPULIST BASE,
THE GRASSROOTS BASE IS GREAT IN
DISTRIBUTING, BUT YOU NEED AN
ORGANIZED, PAID CIRCUMSTANCE IS
LATER FRAMEWORK -- CIRCULATOR
FRAMEWORK.
MONEY IS NEEDED.
THIS CAN BE DONE, BUT THEY DON’T
WANT PEOPLE TO THINK BIG NEWS
ABOUT THIS GREAT SUPPORT MAKES
IT DONE.
IT’S NOT DONE.
WE HAVE TO START -- THEY HAVE
UNTIL MARCH.
THAT’S NOT A LOT OF TIME, AND
WE’VE GOT TO GET THIS DONE.
IT IS THE VERY LEAST THAT
AMERICANS CAN PULL OFF, AND
WE’VE DONE IT BEFORE, AND SO
KEEP THAT IN MIND.
THEY CAN DO IT.
THEY NEED TO GET PAST THE 1.5
MILLION, OF COURSE, BECAUSE SOME
OF THOSE SIGNATURES WON’T BE
GOOD, AND THEY REALIZE THAT.
BUT IT CERTAINLY IS A DOABLE
FRAMEWORK.
GRIFF: JUST IN THE TIME WE’VE
GOT, ABOUT 30 SECONDS LEFT, HOW
IMPORTANT IS IT RAISING
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE GOVERNOR’S
TIES TO THIS LOBBYIST, KIPNY,
THAT- KIPNY, THAT HE WAS AT THIS
50 EVIDENT BIRTHDAY PARTY AT THE
FRENCH LAUNDRY IN.
>> YEAH.
WELL, YOU KNOW, I ACQUAINT
CORRUPTION LIKE A BAG OF POTATO
CHIPS, YOU DON’T DO IT JUST
ONCE, RIGHT?
YOU KEEP GOING.
IN THIS CASE IT’S LIKE A PILE OF
TRASH.
YOU DON’T DIG TRUE THE TRASH
TO -- THROUGH THE TRASH TO FIND
THE SWEET SMELLING ROSES.
THERE’S MORE UNDERNEITHER.
HE’S BEEN A FAILURE AT
GOVERNING, AND NOW YOU’VE GOT A
GUY WHO WRITES HIS SPEECHES WHO
WAS PART OF THIS FRENCH LAUNDRY
DINNER, THE CONCERN IS THAT
GAVIN NEWSOM IS DOING THINGS
THAT BENEFIT THAT LOBBYIST AND
THOSE INTERESTS AS OPPOSED TO
BENEFITING IF PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND HOW DO YOU KNOW?
BECAUSE THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA
IN DIRE STRAITS, AND GAVIN
NEWSOM AND HIS FRIENDS ARE NOT.
GRIFF: TAMMY BRUCE KICKING OFF
2021 WITH A GREAT LINE.